hi glad you could make it welcome
- beauty pies I can see today we're
gonna play some awesome games you ready
let's do yes first game it's called
deadbolt it looks [ __ ] awesome kill
all the enemies Hey and the skull guy
with an awesome suit that guy is on the
pooper I can go up pick up a knife
ooh hey buddy piece of [ __ ]
oh god that guy is ready now switch
light yes ha ha no [ __ ] got me this is
really [ __ ] cool ok ah [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hi friend I'm a [ __ ] what am I
supposed to do [ __ ] shot me in the dick
[ __ ] shot me in there oh I can throw
the knife nice hi friend ah knock any -
oh hey you caught my gun thanks friend
oh no it's it's Santa Claus
please have your girls for you sorry I
don't know what it is oh my god I get
really excited by murdering people
surprise [ __ ] Oh what is this
intervention appear out of toilets gay
man come on man go without him
no I gotta kill him yeah he was [ __ ]
awesome
well I think that that was the end of it
it's still [ __ ] awesome I gotta say
next game is almost as good but not
quite I have to be honest
flip flip baby girl
flip over tables get points don't learn
out of ten [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna flip
don't watch for cables stupid demo ah
best game ever
IGN ten out of ten there it is table
flipper simulator 2015 I waited all my
life for a game where where my wildest
fantasies can come true thank you thank
you developers thanks this one will go
to hell [ __ ] I love you please don't
kill me shut up you're a day but damn it
you ruined my last table
so you think you know a lot about women
do you expert in the female form are you
well it's time to prove it Punk
let's play boobs butt or shoulder this
game is sexist let's play that will be
boobs I know my milkers thank you very
much
that will be a shoulder good job way to
spot the shoulder hey what can I say so
Jimmy I'm a shoulder man that is an
armpit that is the shoulder baby Wow
that's the shoulder I got all the
shoulders right I love the shoulders
what does Jennifer love you would call
her boobs Thelma and Louise why did I
know that that's did he call me gay
that's boobs oh so close
well not really you were way off you
suck but I got it right [ __ ] [ __ ]
you rock dude seriously hard I want to
buy you a beer good man drink bill nice
game baby
scheme has 10 million views Oh
Newgrounds hope you guys enjoy this
video hit that like button if you want
more 3 free games for pants thank you
both so much for watching and becoming a
bro by subscribing cuz I need more
subscribers please please hit me more
please now see you boys in the next one